[Musique]
coup sur coup quatre secondes et vous
venez d'intégrer le groupe de touche pas
à mon poste qu'est ce que ce groupe
c'est un groupe dans lequel on pense
qu'on peut rire de la télévision et oui
on en a marre des émissions médias
sérieuse n'est ce pas le public
et si on veut rire si les mots thierry
finet plaisir vous êtes le plus chic de
l'émission euros oui je me suis dit
qu'il y mettre une cravate je me
démarque comme un petit peu tout le
monde vous vous démarquez je vous le
confirme avec mais également jean michel
maire on peut bien expliquer qu'il est
fier d'avoir ça va bientôt michel
barrette fonctionne merci jean michel et
enfin christophe carrière de l'express
est également sosie officiel capillaire
de jean michel jarre
merci d'être avec nous
denis brogniart est avec nous ce soir
merci d'être avec nous tient à coeur
bonjour à tous premiers invités de tous
par au poste où il est un donneur pour
moi pour nous aussi on plus on a pris
quelqu'un qui faisait beaucoup
d'audience a cartonné la semaine
dernière koh lanta heureusement n'a pas
commencé la semaine dernière alors pas
pu éviter le choc des héros
je sais pas si vous vous souvenez vous
dire en colère il n'a pas voulu que je
lui tienne sa flamme oui c'est vrai il a
pris le bras comme ça la main de moundir
face à mon petit bras flux et je fais
autant vous dire que je les ai sentis
pousser encore la barque la grève et à
ce moment là la seule chose que j'ai
trouvée parce qu'il me dit non non non
non je veux bien que tu étais une flamme
mais on va dans la forêt imaginez c'est
comme ce plateau là il ya quand même
huit ou neuf caméras on peut pas partir
dans la forêt comme ça en freestyle et
paloxi kiemsa lui faire c'est trouver
une idée pour qu'ils puissent accepter
que j'étais une sa flamme je me suis dit
tiens là tu es dos aux aventuriers qui
sont éliminés si je te mettais de face
et rachidi vous allez être face à ceux
qui vous ont éliminé et là il m'a dit
d'accord à donner puisque tout le monde
sait ou presque qui a rencontré son ca
son épouse sa charmante épouse suzy en
commenta comment quand vous avez fait
vous pour la pour la charmée sur le jeu
parce que vous aviez d'autres choses en
tête j'imagine que vous avez dû mener à
la fois le jeu et ont une temps le jeu
de la séduction la justice comme chez
pas faire deux choses à la fois g
j'ai opéré cette séduction avant le
début du jeu j'avais toujours cinq six
jours avant le début du tournage et
c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai réussi à
séduire
est-ce que vous avez séduit votre
fiancée comme comme dans koh lanta c'est
à dire vous avez les mêmes codes
c'est à dire quand vous lui parlez chéri
la sentence est irrévocable
alors tu quittes vous chéri quand ton
sac va récupérer ton flambeau et
viendront jour pour les amoureux de
l'émission qui n'ont pas suivi après
l'on gagne un voyage mais
malheureusement le coût de ces brisé
avant qu'il parte d'un mois le temps de
mettre les pieds dans l'avion s'est
brisé et les moi aussi je suis line donc
moi je prends au sénat mais oui vous
êtes surtout les gemmes non je prends
comme une surchauffe et sur moundir hall
connaît jean michel merle merci jean
michel mr applaudissements polis denis
qu'est-ce que vous êtes devant vous mais
surtout une croissance mais qu'est-ce
que je suis petit mois c'est surtout ça
en plus non j'ai une sarkozettes non
mais il a une espèce de petit portrait
la volée et venez bonnet vrai débat
venir montrer le téléspectateur rien et
c'est une petite règle est là c'est
normal
là c'est la position anna hanouna merci
c'est mon président notre président qui
m'a offert cette petite blague est merci
denis